what chat GPT is doing it's really
telling us a science fact it's telling
us human language which is sort of a
pinnacle of our achievement is in some
sense not as complicated as we thought
there were regularities in human
language which chat gbt had discovered
that we kind of should have known we
there for the last couple of thousand
years but we didn't now we kind of knew
that the language was made up in
sentences that went noun verb noun and
so on but what chat GPT is showing us is
something about the further structure
the way that you put together sentences
based on the kinds of combinations of
words that can mean things